في هذه المباشره هي من نوع اخر هي قصه
الموت النازحين السوريين الذين انتقلوا من
حمص وادلب والذي قيا الى هذه المنطقه
كانوا في المخيمات منذ السنوات الماضيه ثم
انتقلوا الى الشقق التي استاجروها
واشتروها ولكن منذ اربعه ايام عادوا ليس
الى المخيمات وانما الى هذه الزوايا تحت
هذه المؤسسات والمحلات التجاريه قطع من
النايلون علها ترضع عنهم قساوه البرد
وعلها ايضا
تاتي اليهم بشيء من الدفء المساله هنا في
هذا ليس المطالبه بتامين الطعام او الشراب
انما المساله هي فقط والاصوات ترتفع انه
في البنايه التي على جنبنا لا زالت طفله
منذ اربعه ايام تحت ووردها متاكد انها قد
توفيت هو يطالب فقط ان ياتي الدفاع المدني
يقول انا اريد ان اذهب بها فقط الى
المقبره واريد ان احفظ لها هذه
احفظ لها هذه العادات والتقاليد الدينيه
بان اقوم بحمل اقله ابنتي بعد هذه الايام
الى المقبره معي